what up its your boy moon night with  three days you get it destination what  up its you boy Middle Eastern man that's  worse dear Lord you can't tell but my  eyes are closed  what up its your boy Bo tonight in this  other guy over here we're going to be  streaming on Wednesday at 3 o'clock  Mountain time right good call  hey what's happening Wednesday what's  going on hi your boy moon night and Josh  we're going to be streaming on Wednesday  the original plan was Tuesday but this  boy has work he's got to get that money  for for his surgery so we're going to  stream Wednesday from 3 join us we're  going to be playing spider-man  PlayStation 1 the whole thing the whole  game once dreams will be answering fan  questions will be showing extra stuff  it's going to be a grand old times the  30,000 subscriber special so so look  forward to it  okay okay  oh are you going go on okay all right  yeah baby okay  [Music]  looking oh God